[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
attack on Titan video since our previous
attack on Titan Theory videos generated
a lot of support from you guys and
sparked a great discussion in the
comments in this video we will be
looking at some more attack on Titan
theories in particular we will be
looking at the theories that Armin and
or any might be members of an LD and
noble family now I'm not the first
person to talk about these theories of
course and the arming Theory especially
has been around for a while but after
noticing some really interesting details
in the last few chapters of the manga
some things have begun to come together
in my mind and that is why I decided to
make this video and test these theories
out based on the latest evidence we have
of course this video will contain manga
spoilers up to the latest chapters so
proceed with extreme caution
however while we will be talking about
spoilers in order to examine the
theories the theories themselves are not
spoilers as of right now they are just
speculation by the way one of the small
details in the last few chapters that
first gave me the idea to make this
video was this in Chapter 97 we see a
scene in which Annie is in disguise
while trying to gather Intel about the
royal family on Paradise Island in this
scene she briefly comes into contact
with Kenny the Ripper but she manages to
escape when I first saw Annie's face in
this scene I couldn't help but think of
something doesn't Annie here look a lot
like someone else we know someone with
royal blood more on this later but first
let's talk about Armin and of course if
you like these types of videos I want to
see more be sure to Warhammer smash that
like button and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell now we know
that Armin alert was one of the few
people on Paradise Island who knew about
the world outside the walls even before
the fall of Shingen Tina district and
this is because he found a banned book
about the outside world that belonged to
his grandfather on top of that Armin's
parents clearly knew about the outside
world as they had actually constructed a
hot air balloon in an attempt to fly
over the walls and reach the outside
world but sadly they were killed by the
military police brigade before they
could carry out their plan but the
question is how could the alert family
have known this and how could they have
come across this banned knowledge in the
first place while reading chapter 96 of
the manga something struck me during a
conversation between Annie bertolt and
Reiner we learned that the timers were
the ones who told them our land army
that the King behind the walls is tied
down by the promise of pacifism and that
he wouldn't use the power of the
founding titan to attack Marlay even if
the walls were breached this means that
the Tiber family despite being in Marlay
still has accurate intelligence about
what is going on behind the walls and
this made me think that the Tiber x'
must have LDN spies inside the walls who
are giving them this information
could these LDN spies be members of the
Tiber family who have infiltrated the
walls generations ago and changed their
names in order to hide their identity
could Arman's ancestors be timers who
came to paradise as spies and could this
be the reason why the alert family has
access to band knowledge that they were
never supposed to possess over too many
decades the are lurtz may have stopped
being spies and become just normal LD
ends living behind the walls but the
fact is that even if armand isn't aware
of it he could have royal blood of the
Tiber family running through his veins
if armand does have royal blood then it
would make sense for him to be a Tiber
rather than a Rees if the are lurtz were
members of the Reese family as many have
speculated in the past then it is very
likely that the Reese family would have
known about their existence as they kept
a close watch on what was going on
within the
walls but if the are lurtz were members
of a different royal family the tie
burrs then they could hide inside the
walls effectively without anyone knowing
their true identity to add to this one
thing that I always thought was a major
plot hole in the attack on Titan story
and the only one that really bothers me
because otherwise I really love the
story was the fact that Marley sent four
children
Marcell Reiner bertolt and Annie two
parodies on their own now these children
may have been exceptional fighters but
how foolish would the Malayan government
be to give four Titan shifter powers
into the hands of children and send
those children into enemy territory
alone what if the children due to their
lack of experience screwed up and Marley
lost all four Titan powers to the LD ins
on the island what a massive blow that
would be to the military of Marley this
whole plan would have made a lot more
sense if Marley or at least the tiber
family had spies inside the walls who
could keep an eye on the four young
warriors to make sure that everything
was going according to plan
if we accept that the timers did in fact
have a network of spies inside the walls
a network that might have at some point
included the alert family then
everything begins to fall into place a
lot more smoothly another reason that
could suggest that Armin has royal blood
is of course his physical appearance and
many have pointed out that his hair
color eye color and other physical
characteristics suggest that he could
have royal blood in fact Arman resembles
the royal family so closely that he was
used as a body double for historia the
current Queen in addition a youtuber
known as dark logic studios even made a
video that suggests that Armin's
features including the unique shape of
his nose closely resemble the features
of Willy Tiber the head of the Tiber
family and the current holder of the
Warhammer Titan if you want to check out
that video I will leave the link in the
description it's pretty interesting
personally I don't think that Arman's
physical appearance alone is enough to
he has royal blood because there are
other blonde characters in the story who
are not Royals but when combined with
all the other factors including having
banned books I think that we can make a
pretty compelling case for Armand
potentially having royal blood and of
course if he does have royal blood this
would have major implications on the
story it means that Armand's colossus
titan power will be far more deadly than
Berthold form because LD ends with royal
blood who become shifters have greater
power and additional abilities as
compared to shifters possessed by
regular ldiots
if Armin really does have royal blood I
can only imagine how strong his Colossus
Titan will be do you think that Armin
has royal blood
could he be a member of the Tiber family
without even knowing it let me know down
in the comments and now on to any there
are a number of factors that make me
think that any could also have royal
blood and that she could also
potentially be a member of the Tiber
royal family as I mentioned at the
beginning of the video it was any
stunning resemblance to Zeke's mother
and grisha's first wife Deena Fritz aka
Deena Yeager that first got me thinking
about this remember that
ISA Emma does not draw characters in
such a similar fashion by coincidence
and we've already seen with historia
that in chapter 65 isayama deliberately
depicted her in a very similar way to
how Amir Fritz is usually depicted as
foreshadowing that just like Amir Fritz
historia would also become queen of the
ldiots aside from the fact that Annie
also has the physical features of
someone who could have royal blood
including the blond hair and blue with
gray eyes there are also some very
interesting things about Annie's
backstory that are worth thinking about
unlike most of the other warriors of
Marlay and he does not consider
inheriting the female Titan to be an
honor and she is extremely skeptical of
Marlon propaganda as if she knows
something that the others do not she
first learned how to fight from her
father when she was still a child but
this is not because she wanted to rather
her father insisted on teaching her
and one point and he says that just like
edit and Reiner her father was carried
away with ideals that had nothing to do
with reality we also see in chapter 33
Andy's father apologizing to her saying
that he was wrong about something and he
warns her to see the whole world as her
enemy now her father might have trained
a knee because he wanted her to be a
warrior so that their family could get
honorary merlion status but that's only
one possibility although many assumed
that Annie is from the lab aerial
internment Zone we don't have
confirmation of this the few scenes that
we do see of Annie and her father
appeared to be happening somewhere out
in nature which doesn't look likely
Barry owed to me so what if Annie and
her father were not actually regular LD
ins living in lis burial what if they
were members of the tiber family but for
some reason they fell out of favor with
the rest of the timers maybe Annie's
father did something wrong something
against the timers which would explain
him apologizing and saying he was wrong
maybe the reason Annie became a warrior
was not to get honorary Marlon
citizenship but rather as a way for her
family to make up for her father's
mistake whatever it was and to get back
into the tiber family's good graces if
Annie's father's ideals led him to
believe in the Marlon cause like Ryder's
mother then why would he warned Annie
that she should see the whole world as
her enemy the whole world would of
course include Marlay so it wouldn't be
too far of a stretch to say that Annie's
father was not really a supporter of the
Malayan military and he may have been a
rogue Tibor who did something wrong such
as helping the LDN restorationist for
instance and who was forced to give up
his daughter to the warrior program in
order to atone for his sin also let's
not forget that Annie's female Titan has
some very unique abilities along with
having high endurance impressive
versatility on different types of
terrain and the ability to harden parts
of her body and he can also control
mindless Titans by calling them to her
with her voice remember
that the only other Titan shifters that
have demonstrated the ability to control
mindless Titans are defunding Titan and
the Beast IP now here's the important
thing the founding Titan can control
mindless titans when it is possessed by
a member of the royal family and by
Annan only when he comes into direct
contact with royal blood
in his case Deana Yeager in her smiling
Titan form the current beast Titan has
unique abilities that no previous beast
Titan had and he can control mindless
Titans because its current possessor is
Zeke Yeager Dena son who also has royal
blood so wise Annie's female Titan the
only other shifter that can control
mindless Titans could it be that her
ability to summon mindless Titans is not
an ability possessed by every female
Titan but an ability unique to Annie
because Annie is in fact a member of the
royal family and her royal blood allows
her to control mindless Titans this is a
really interesting question in my mind
and I am really looking forward to
learning more about both Annie and
Arman's bloodline as the story moves
forward and I honestly can't wait to see
any emerge from that damn Crystal cocoon
because I think she still has some
important secrets to reveal about her
background so what do you guys think is
it possible that Armin and Annie have
royal blood and if so what does this
mean for the future of the story let me
know down below and of course these are
just theories speculations we don't have
definitive evidence on this so don't
think that I'm trying to convince you
I'm just trying to put the ideas out
there and start up a good conversation
if you want to discuss attack on titan
theories and other anime theories feel
free to join our discord server link in
the description we have a special
section for anime theories discussion
right there in the server if you like
these types of videos be sure to
warhammer smash that like button to let
me know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell as always thank you so
much for watching stay tuned to the
channel for a lot more attack on titan
content and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]